today's guest has made over a dozen
appearances on The Tonight Show with Jay
Leno he is the founder of the Institute
for greatly endangered and rare species
tige RS in Myrtle Beach South Carolina
and is the owner of Myrtle Beach Safari
in Myrtle Beach South Carolina today's
guests from the tiger King is Bo Gavin
doc Antal
[Music]
it uh can you hear me I can how you
doing Oh wonderful thank you so much for
joining uh
joining me this afternoon bro glad to be
on god we got to put it together yeah
yeah thank you for your patience
chatting here with da canto from Myrtle
Beach Safari which I'll probably is it
the premier cat visitation spot in in
the US would you say in the world by far
there's no place like this you know
there we just have this fabulous
location that people can have such a
grand time at but is really a palace for
the wildlife in our care and it looks
really higher-end it looks more like the
Four Seasons of Animalia over there by
you where as opposed to you know you
look at you know a place like Joe exotic
is running more of like a still a
beautiful place but a little bit more
you know something you'd see it like
maybe you're like a rural carnival or
something like that yeah I mean you know
it's the opportunity of time and money
for us this is the going 39 years of
doing this I've had the blessing of
engaging in the biz and being around
started working so heavily in the 80s
and 90s work in Hollywood and doing
stuff and we made a spin shura and
Jungle Book and dr. Doolittle and 500
movie and television projects over the
round-the-world and all that led me to a
different vision of how to do it and the
financial opportunity to create
something that could have that five star
appeal go do you never had the time
never had the money and I am in this
glorious spot it is one of the hotspots
of tourism in the world here in Myrtle
Beach here we go yeah beautiful 20
million people come here every year so
it's so filled with people looking for
adventure and opportunity from all over
the world the middle of nowhere Oklahoma
is a hard place to do something there's
only three things that matter right
location location location location Amen
man you guys have a great location over
there a lot of people when they watch
you in the tiger King documentary they
see not only a man that's able
really wrangle pets but also a man
that's really right able to wrangle
females you know I think a lot of men
were impressed a lot of men I'm a man
you know for now but uh I live in
Hollywood you never know what they're
gonna try to do to me but a lot of men
were just as impressed with your ability
to attract females as to attract you
know this sort of Tarzan atmosphere with
the animals does does the way you relate
to women in the way you relate to
animals is there any is there is there
some similarities there no I mean come
on I'm a single guy I was married you
know 25 years ago but I'm a single guy I
got girlfriends they come and gone over
the years I mean it can't be unique that
I have girlfriends it's just that they
got put on a screen and said this um and
then they included all of my son's
fiance and my grandma my granddaughters
and everybody else you're like look at
their lineup of all those ladies those
ladies are are my relatives and or the
significant others of my staff and my
friends and stuff that are here helping
me out I see so this so the documentary
really they tacked on a few extra ladies
to your to your Tiger Tail I guess yeah
I mean the count was just like going up
like bodies hit the floor they're like
oh my god you're seven nine eleven there
it's crazy land you know uh that's not
how it goes by any means you know and
the tales of woe that somebody wants to
say or just the judgmental insanity of
people yeah oh my god this guy's got
girlfriends what on earth and that is
part of Americana for me
amen no I agree look I think a lot of
men a lot of people were probably
jealous if even at the the assumption of
it did you get a lot of people reaching
out saying that's wrong you shouldn't
have that type of life's not like we did
you get a lot of lifestyle judgment
lifestyle judgment stop and just somehow
that the ladies are very young and are
taking advantage of being all from the
driller that was coming out of the one
unique characters mouth that talked on
their the girls that are here these are
women in their 40s you know roll it up
on 50 those are the key characters vid
ya help run the preserve these aren't
teenagers that are walking around here
granted some of them have been here for
decades but these are girls that operate
this facility that are kick-ass
lion-tamer girls who hold their own and
have been doing so and operating the
facility autonomous from me I don't even
have to be here and they can make it
roll along and have everything work out
oh that's impressive eeeh no it
definitely seems like a lot of tough
women there I'm a lot of you know
confident competent ladies what is it
about a cat that women love a cat what
is it about a cat I mean it just is this
incredible symbol of beauty power and
grace a tiger is the sexiest thing in
the world it's covered in that
incredible primordial calligraphy those
amazing stripes against that super
orange background it's like an unreal
superhero character everybody's kind of
got a vibe of loving Tigers and when you
see one in person it just carries
forward it makes people inside it people
want to get their hands on them and when
you get the incredible opportunity that
I've gotten and some of the senior staff
that are here where you have great big
600 to 900 and 22 pound tigers come up
and lay their neck on you and rub and
you can hold walk with them you know
there's the girls that jump on their
back and they run off and they ride them
this is a unbelievable privilege it's
just you are communing with a slice of
nature in its greatest it's a reflection
in a tiger's face there's like a
reflection of nature at its purest
you're looking out at the eyes of God in
a way when a tiger's staring into your
face it is what I call God's greatest
paint job just a fabulous kid and
they're incredible in their little
because they're just miniature Tigers
they look just like big Tigers which is
so unique you know not a lot of little
things look just like the big things oh
yeah he's got that super appeal when
they're young and people have the
opportunity to meet them and interact
with them and it's a bucket list with so
many people but
right oh yeah I want to see a tiger and
they want to see a big tiger a lot of
them think man I want to pet a big tiger
now you know I've heard you talking a
little bit watching your show up and
watching you know that you this thing
and and and your oh yeah king of this
thing you know some people are a little
hesitant they think that a tiger is
gonna do something incorrect but our big
tigers are fabulous guys you know we did
it we made Jim Carrey look like the pet
detective we made Eddie Murphy look like
dr. Doolittle it's that we have a great
relationship with these unbelievable big
predators and we're able to have them
interact with us and act as though they
are tame they're not I certainly don't
think anybody should take one home hey
do not Mia X they're not something that
I think the untrained should do anymore
and you should be out doing you know
driving a racecar 250 miles an hour like
the pros do it's something that takes
time to learn how to do in decades of
devotion and understanding which most
people never gather yeah we missed most
you don't have the opportunity to you
know and yeah it's definitely like I
think that's one of the most fascinating
things about Tiger King documentary and
just learn for a lot of the nation to
learn about you kind of you know cat
liaison men who are able to really
interact with these animals is that
momenti to be that bridge between humans
and just cat them you know yep and it's
it's just something that is very
complicated right it's not something
simple to do and you see people like
Carol who's a fool with her cats she got
out there she tried to hug and kiss them
and play with them it all fell apart
that's the normal story Joe certainly
has had a bunch of big cats around but
as they matured and became older cats
almost all the relationships have fallen
apart the rest of the characters on the
show none of them have those great
relationships with big adult cats
outside of enclosures where they're
freely interacting and doing what duty
you see my son Cody I think you have
seen him at Marea Sandman that's out
there with gigantic adult Tigers
wrestling ride and swim and playing the
same as I did for my whole youth and I
still do
all the time now he's just the flash and
the beautiful guy out there making it
like it's so simple that is super rare
he's one of a kind left in the world was
it like 13 million people following him
on social media he has such a unique
presence and such a fabulous thing going
on it's different to anybody else
yeah he's able to really get out there
and interact with those cats I mean I
definitely noticed that I'll check I was
checking out some of his YouTube videos
yesterday when when you look at the
documentary do you see like where did
they go wrong like are there things that
obviously they blew out of proportion I
mean obviously they you know tried to
classify or make it just vaguely look
like you're your granddaughter could be
what you know a woman you're dating or
something but what else do they do what
else did they capture wrong or what else
did we not get the true story on when
you look at it I mean the huge line they
stepped over was there at the end
bringing up on the black screen that
they have asked me about some
inappropriateness with tiger cubs and I
haven't answered but in fact these guys
talked to me for maybe five full days of
filming and three or four half days they
asked me every question in the world 99%
of them had nothing to do with anything
to become King and they just pick and
chose little pieces of course I run this
incredible world-class operation I have
tiger cubs that live with me
cradle-to-grave no Tiger babies are ever
going to be euthanized they're ever
gonna be pushed out of the way they're
incredibly precious to us
all the way from what they provide us to
their very nature who they have hyper
value they're super rare
we are reproduce that have all been
genetically tested from the time they're
young and from their grandparents and
great-grandparents and we genetically
test them to know that these are some of
the most genetically diverse Tigers on
earth the only ones left
on the planet with this genetic makeup
we've done house through world-class
genetics the continued to work for us
with us and those guys have been able to
see this incredibly
opportunity we have and this is a bank
against the potential eventual
extinction Tigers are super rare
they all know yeah I never see a tiger
you can go buy a tiger that's just a
complete joke
I cannot go buy a tiger I know everybody
that's ever been around
99% of everyone who ever used to do it
is gone there is no one that has a tiger
for sale that you can solicit and find
it is a felony it you know yeah you can
buy some heroin I guess somewhere but
it's a heck of a step to going to
literally be involved with whoever it is
that to move and sell any kind of super
illegal product and that for the tiger
would be I make up as their a black
market is there a birthmark it's not
America there's a black market in Laos
or Cambodia or you know places in
Southeast Asia where people still
readily consume Tigers the greatest
threat the tiger has is being consumed
by people who think that the incredible
power and grace of the tiger will be
given to them somehow by eating its
parts and pieces all the way from its
testicles to its whiskers a different
part yeah different vibe and fix you up
but in America a tiger cub is precious
and amazingly rare there is no surplus
of tiger cubs in North America there's
virtually no one doing anything with
comes except the characters on the film
of which most of those people are out or
on their way out they no longer have a
licence you know there's there is no
more Tim Stark there is no more of a
number of those characters and if
they're not there right on the precipice
of falling off we've never had a single
violation of any kind and at the end
they also said we were raided
we're not yeah yeah you guys had that
raid where December they said you guys
had a raid that came through their dock
for the past we had an inquiry from
Virginia magistrate there who wanted to
get some DNA from some lion cubs that we
had and so what are they doing with the
DNA do you think somebody in Virginia is
having a meltdown case with them about
animal rights thing you know in a small
hometown zoo that they don't like and
they want to close it down they have
closed
he didn't explain to them in some
capacity what they what they wanted to
hear about some baby lions that were
born there Lions were born there he
called me and said I have lions I can't
take care of would you take them I would
be happy to give them to you
he said yes my daughter got in car
picked him up and brought him back
completely legal transaction
everything's michi lady you didn't tell
anybody what he did he didn't explain it
right he gotten some beef with them and
they came down here to say do you have
those lines and I said yes he said we
believe you but we have to have an
equivocal proof we've got to know that
that's the lines let's take DNA from
those lines and we'll be on our way I
was never found
or even questioned of doing anything
wrong having stings or any line we're
just here with our wildlife having this
amazing setup go on and just trying to
make things smooth so the guests could
see us and everybody had the greatest
experience before it seems wonderful
we're cleaned up a little bit because of
the cove it looks like everybody yeah
you know we um we're waiting for a guy's
business say again is that affecting you
guys business right now the curly yeah
we're 98 percent down you know there's
no doubt the whole thing is definitely
shifted in in capacity the Myrtle Beach
the town of Myrtle Beach which can have
yeah 150 thousand hotel rooms you can't
rent a room it's closed up Wow and you
come here Cody Oh Cody 0:d was walking
in I know he's out taking a walk he was
gonna come say hi and see what was
happening what's happening he's got some
big footsteps give me a wild man who's
this oh come here yeah looking good
looking good
Cody gang bruh oh that's a beautiful
animal right there what is that this is
Bali the chimp one of Cody's brothers
that hangs out with us here and is
hanging around he's uh he just goes out
and plays he comes in every evening and
has a big dinner party with us and hangs
around has a lovely time doing that
stuff yeah Wow how long is he how long
is his body oh he's got a nice hand he's
a big guy he's well over a hundred
pounds
he's about four feet tall he's a Indian
on nine years old
and Cody and dokdo you guys in
interacting with animals so closely
especially here like volley does it make
you feel more like evolution or does you
still think that there's a one that
there's a uh there's a religious element
like what kind of comes into your soul
when you're this close to animals I mean
I think that there is potentially a
creator to the universe right I believe
that I some kind of divine fingerprint
that helps organize us all out I don't
know that anybody's down there doing day
to day calls on how we behave but I
think that there is something
spectacular in what was made up and how
it all happened
please think I got a question
volley do you think that uh Carroll
Baskin had anything to do with their
husband's disappearance that's really
what I think a lot of people want to
know he's run them up he's over there
wrastlin with Cody hey guys I hate to
interrupt this episode but I need to
tell you about keeps who is supporting
this past weekend it is keeps and you
can support them and support our podcast
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness and
that's where baldness comes and gets at
you get such a head by the time they are
35 years of age huh so right around that
age edge
you got that MP be looking for you son
that male pattern baldness the good news
is with today's advancements in science
keeps offers proven treatments that can
combat the symptoms of hair loss and
help you keep the hair you have and
that's one thing that's critical and
that's one thing that I love about keeps
is that it's helping me hold on to what
I got a lot of people thinking okay
let's go let's regenerate let's do this
but let's start with keeping which you
have keep you don't have to go broke to
avoid going bald keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda-approved
hair loss products out there some of me
some of you have may have tried them
before but probably never for this price
that's what keeps does keeps is offering
you that price
prevention is key keeps treatment really
works they're up to 90 percent effective
at reducing and stopping further hair
loss that's the game plan
find out why keeps has more 5-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100 thousand men trust keeps for
their hair loss prevention medication if
you're ready to take action and you
should be you should be hold on to that
mane
you want to hold on to that man if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss go to keeps calm
that's ke EPS calm / Theo th EO to
receive your first month of treatment
for free I mean what else can you ask
for
that's ke EPS calm / th EO if you're
wondering about your hair you're if
you're worried about your hair you're
wondering about your hair and one of
them what you're gonna look like if you
lose it all
then then eliminate that from the
equation and use keeps it works support
this past weekend keeps calm / Theo he
took your coat off and stood in the rain
you're always crazy like that and if you
guys ever heard that old song about jus
L or jewel or jus jewel Joe L but um but
man I'll never forget that post mates
fella that came it was raining and he
you know I shared about it on my
instagrams but the man was just he was
there and he was gone and then I was
alone I had food but you know my heart
was still empty but it could be
different for you if you try post mates
from an early morning breakfast burrito
if you want that rise and shine in your
frickin face hole or if you want that
hit of wine after work huh
you want that tangy berry juice after
work you want that freakin grape cape
bro you know what I'm saying you want to
get wind up and feel like you're
Superman or superwoman sometimes
whatever you want you need to deliver it
fast and that's where post mates comes
in post mace doesn't just deliver
burgers and
sushi they actually make your life
easier especially these days you know
maybe going out to the market you're
concerned about getting you know about
flu symptoms or this or that but post
mates can help grocery delivery whatever
you can think of delivery convenience
stores clothing stores you name it no
more trips to the store no more
late-night stealing mom's car you know
driving 200 miles to get a waffle don't
worry don't live like that just download
post mates on iOS or Android and if you
are if you already have it downloaded
again and support this past weekend
because we have this offer for a limited
time post mates is giving our listeners
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days to start your free
deliveries download the app and use code
weekend
that's code weekend for $100 of free
delivery credit with no minimum purchase
for your first 7 days when you download
the post mates app anything you need
anytime you need it post made it don't
even put your shoes on don't go get in
the car don't get on the skateboard post
made it don't get in your hot air
balloon and crank that thing up because
you're going to get a slushy or a snow
cone post made it bucco have them bring
it to you and support the podcast you
can do it just go to post mates dot-com
download the app and use the code
weekend $100 of free delivery credit
with no minimum purchase for your first
7 days and now back to the episode so
doc in a video I saw online Carol Baskin
who's also another you know she's
another cat owner and farmer that's
featured in the in the documentary Carol
Carol really pushes the envelope of you
guys miss handling cub treatment over
there right some some crazy illusion of
it you know the cob is a super valuable
character that is too why because why's
the cups are valuable
he created likewise aw why is it all
about the Cubs like everyone's always
like the Cubs the Cubs the Cubs why is
that the
real reason is it just they know it's
going to hit the heartstrings of people
so they want to create drama unfounded
unprecedented endless drama people like
peril and Peeta just trying to make up a
story of course the Cubs are super
valuable to us as individuals as
characters that hold vital genetics to
our ongoing program almost 40 years
where we've been holding these family of
tigers together I've known several
hundred Tigers in that time trying to
add them hold up that genetics which may
in fact save the tiger and in through
that make it that they'll even be Tigers
on the planet in time to come a baby
tiger needs TLC around the clock you
just can't rough them and handle them in
some way that's inappropriate they are
cared for round-the-clock handled super
minimally you know they pretend like
we're passing them off in a line 20
minutes people come they get a 20-minute
interaction three days a week that's it
one hour whatever and what about when
they age out of kind of that sugar realm
where people are loving them and you
know like they start to become you know
hit the terrible twos you know like even
like children do do you guys is there is
there a Underground Railroad or
something where you guys get rid of
Tigers at that point or is there you
know what's the real deal you see all
those those guys that are with Cody
those are Cody's uh
you know brothers and sisters that he's
out there with all day he's got every
color every size every shape boys girls
we continually have a relationship with
those guys throughout their life cradle
to grave they're important characters
that on the preserve we swim with them
in a huge fool they're gonna be great
big guys for that we have a big tiger
run where we have a tiger chase
high-speed lures we have ten Tigers that
are set up to throw and chase that lure
system and be part of the whole
interactive part of the tour and big
Tigers come out twenty two adults are on
our big night Safari dinner party every
Tiger has a vital importance to us and
is like critical characters plus this
idea that someone would do that taking a
tiger and killing it taking a tiger and
getting rid of I wouldn't do it it's a
crime and do it unless the tiger attack
me or something I probably would
do it now it's immoral it's it's it's a
no purpose to it and it's not going to
be something that creates a benefit of
business you need this Tiger tonight
therefore his genetics or his beauty for
what he's going to be able to do later
and as an individual he's a highly
important loving caring character that a
girl a boy sat there holding and loving
and giving it a bottle around the clock
and always being with it so these are
our imprinted fur children in their own
way as these are family members you know
and we have the world's oldest cat was
here
the world's oldest bear was here there
are so really retirees here that are
decades old step off it and we modeled
them along so they cross the rain is Joe
viding there I feel like Joe Biden
should be in there as well kind of I
wouldn't be surprised if he qualifies
and that group maybe so yeah obviously
if you guys were doing anything harmful
to animals it would really harm your
business but why do other why is there
such venom between different cat camps
where they're like they're doing this
they're doing this why why isn't there
more of a unified group that we're all
doing the right thing do you feel like
there's a couple reasons one those guys
are out there running a gigantic fund
raising business to get people to send
them money to rescue something in need
so they have to create drama you have to
say these animals need our help today
you give us a dollar
we'll help make this change whether the
change is real or not has nothing to do
with the equation that's right guys who
are pretending to be rescue you look at
my place at shangri-la huge open forest
habitats beautiful waterfalls and ponds
and space everywhere beautiful I've seen
the video online yes some of y'all's
videos online man it is really it is
beautiful I feel like I went to like one
of the covers on remember the job is
witness they give you that cover of the
fan flip well pyridine it would have a
yeah yeah it's beautiful that know that
I'm you look at Carol's place holy cow a
dungeon is so
Lopes like white slavery over there - it
is a very white slavery kind of vibe
she's making four to five million
dollars a year according to her taxes
but it's all donation is that right
what's that but her money is they
they're able to earn money through
donation right that and the other camps
don't do that is that correct right it's
a totally separate thing how they raised
that money and what they're doing with
it you know I mean you got the activists
that are like PETA or a Humane Society
United States who are a vegan world
order they want everybody to be forced
vegetarian they want every human animal
interaction to stop and they will they
say that all zoos are bad and of course
you can't ride a horse you certainly
can't go get a puppy as a matter if you
see a pound every animals better off
dead the head of PETA has said that no
world without puppies would be just fine
me and with me my entire life
and I think it's essential to get that
love and understanding and connection to
ourselves
and animals to have puppies and have
things around in our life and they're
living on another side we really also
work heavily as a wildlife conservation
education organization we have we have
our own camps in the deep jungles of
Sumatra but we hire the Rangers for
we've built the stations we have guys
out every day picking up stairs chasing
poachers we deliver drones around the
world to anti poaching teams of fly
drones and find poachers
we've put millions of dollars into
programs like this those characters have
never even considered doing things like
that it's completely outside of what
they're up to
we're on a different side that is the
American Zoo Association the City zoos
they are running a program where
everybody's equal and everybody can care
for it no one there needs to have their
hands on a tiger so they say puts their
hands on a tiger is wrong and they need
to be right more people go the zoos in
America then all professional sports
events combined we realize there's
billions of dollars at stake in zoo
visitation and I didn't realize that at
all it's huge the big dues are raking in
phenomenal money San Diego Zoo keeps
keeps money in reserve of over half a
billion dollars just to keep things
running their overhead is hundreds of
millions of dollars and it's from the
public pouring money into it because
most of the public loves wildlife and
wants to see it from afar they really
wish they could hold it but most of them
don't even realize it's possible to do
it say securely and beneficially some
we're doing it here creates a big
multi-sided benefit where you get to see
the animals and paid for their wild
project restoration so that they have a
place to live hopefully the Kingsmen
forward as we all make up our mind
whether we're gonna hold the world for
wildlife or if we're gonna hold the
world for these people because we've got
to come up with a decision there for the
wild world be left alone a little bit
everybody wants their slice of it
because it already was that piece
valuable asset you know everything's an
asset
well it's seen if I were an animal I'd
rather live over there with you guys I
feel like because a lot of the zoos are
real [ __ ] honestly yeah they can be
this is this is paulie's brother Cody
what happened he wanted to make it fair
so he wouldn't got bottle.these brother
here and brought Sugriva and how you
doing so good how you doing yeah those
guys right here what's up sugreeva
degree was oh thanks Cody yeah I was
just looking at some of your videos
yesterday I got nervous sometimes man
you and those cats seem real I mean it
got a little WWE in some of the videos
you guys really are having a good time
you know so brave man I got attacked by
a couple animals on my birthday once
when I was young and that really set me
on a bad course with Animalia but it's
coming around more I dated a girl that
had two cats yeah maybe maybe one day
I'll be able to come there and see you
guys I have a question how is the
documentary do you feel like I got
scared at the end of watching Tiger king
that I said I thought to myself man this
is really going to put a damper on this
this kind of like wild experience that
you could have with cats are the most
like innate experience you could have
with cats do you feel like
at all like or at the end did you feel
like this is going to inspire more
people to come to these experiences I
hope it lets people think they can you
know experience it and halves and create
the benefit for the animals in the wild
and for the animals that are here with
us but it is very rare in America
there's very few places that are left
doing it it's very expensive you know
even to consider how it flows and how to
start it and operate it and people don't
even have the knowledge of how how to go
about it so it's disappearing it we we
are an endangered species ourselves
right now the whole thing is slimmed way
up the opposition's being vicious you
know they wish to pass laws it would say
no baby tiger would ever be touched by
anybody ever again they want to take you
right away how its your right to scuba
dive or parachute or you know go 80
miles an hour downhill on skis it should
be your right to interact with wildlife
in any way that you see fit if you're
doing it beneficially for the wildlife
if you're doing it in a safe manner for
both yourself and the wildlife and it
should be a free choice that everyone
has you know want to take it away
because it would disenfranchise someone
like myself there would be a change in
how we went about raising money for the
conservation projects overseas and their
ideas of what's bright would be better
financed right yeah there's a war out
there there's a silly thing called the
big cat Safety Act which is just up our
ridiculous law but it's private owners
from public ownership where they say oh
the big public zoos can have big cats
nobody private can have big cats anymore
it's just like any other business
it sounds like any other business
business realm it's like trying to
trying to kill out the little man I did
feel like that at the end at the end of
the documentary I worried I said man is
this gonna kill the little man you know
or the middle man because I remember
when I was growing up we had a guy by us
that had a couple of animals I don't
even know what one of them was and we go
over there and pet him you know and you
could see the animals and stuff like
that and I felt like it at least gave me
at least uh you
inexperience with animals that was close
to me you know we had on by us we had a
Wildlife Refuge when I was in junior
high and you go to air and feet they got
a um like a camel or something and all
kinds of long animals giraffe and
everything and I'm assuming that once
these kind of things move forward that a
lot of a lot of you guys and those sorts
of things would be shut down that would
be the idea right because the opposition
ultimately wants to say that you can't
have a goldfish you can't have a leather
shoe you can never enter key dinner you
know it's yeah all the way to the
extreme the big money powerful
organizations like PETA and Humane
Society United States are anti all human
interaction or entertainment for pets or
for food I'm a vegetarian but I don't
think you're supposed to be a vegetarian
you Joyce yourself
I can't impose upon you my own concepts
of thinking it's everyone has to make
their own free choice I think that those
ideas of somebody trying to legislate a
what they think is a moral choice for
you is wrong and that's what a lot of
this boils down to is then saying we
know what's best
now there's a whole vehicle concept of
we know how you should really behave and
be treated let us tell you what it is
you can't decide big government right
I like having animals in the wild I like
animals look if I go outside I like
having to stay on a swivel not knowing
what's over there what's over there you
know could be an animal could be a
falcon could be anything I like I like
that that you know I like the I like
there to be some risk involved in my
life you know sometimes everything just
becomes this bump or lifestyle that's
just too much you know it's just it's
just everything's just so I like a
little bit of freelance opportunity yeah
you know I always have that's how we
that's what we're founded on is people
you know we're rolling by the seat of
their own pants
as they see fit so long as they're not
harming others and that they're doing
things according if there's rules sure
there should be rules but the rule says
you can't well that's not part of the
it has to be you can but you've got to
do it in a in a thoughtful right way
yeah I have a question on going back to
the documentary where do you think that
Joe Joe exotic would be if it weren't
for Carol Baskin today I think that he's
had a lot of difficulties that have come
up I think there was other difficult
things besides Carol I think that pita
was a real difficulty and a thorn in his
side I think that Joe was too big and
imploding in his own way I think he was
taking on so much responsibility of so
many animals and I think that that is
just a difficulty in itself there's a
certain point that you have to stop you
know if you can properly care for 100
chickens then you've got 100 chickens
and you built a barn from and that's how
it is you had ten more chickens to there
you start reducing the quality of all
110 chickens now and I think he was
piling it on and that was causing a lot
of pain and suffering for him and that
potentially that was going to expand in
to the staff and to the animals and to
other things it all became tragic in its
own way and it's incredibly difficult to
find people that want to help you so I
had very difficult staff problems you
know he was he was really scraping the
edges sometimes to find people that he
could have do the work there and try and
have the food it cost me a fortune to
feed my cats I have to being a thousand
pounds of food out every day and if it's
not that I would eat or I would expect
my children need I wouldn't expect a
tiger to eat it but they're grabbing all
that old funky meats and secondhand
deliveries and things and that also
creates an implosion things are
unhealthy things can't reproduce things
can't live their best life you everybody
needs care and quality in their life
when you reduce the care you reduce the
quality of the opportunities for them to
eat to sleep for where they can stay
everything oh yes off the edge it was
imploding in his own his own way and I
spoke to him a couple times saying Joe
you've got too many parts here you got
too much going on you need to worry
about care and the center point here and
was he able to hear that like he refer
he's referred to you or he in the
documentary at one point he referred to
you as a mentor and somebody he really
looks up to um was he able to hear that
when you were talking to him when you
kind of when you guys checked in with
each other
he was like I'm I sneeze okay he was
able to hear some of it but hearing it
and enacting it are two different things
saying try and find some better quality
help shoot many restaurants in America
that serve fine food cannot find fine
servers you know many yeah they have
great businesses I have the most
difficult time with staff Joe was at
odds trying to have staff and then he
wanted to be famous you know he got his
wish this way everybody always even
think of careful with the dish for Joe's
more famous is gonna be right now you
know for him this is the crowning moment
in his career and he's oddly not even
free to see it which is uh yeah which is
such a wild thing on the documentary a
lot of uh there seems to be like a lot
of like drug use and behind-the-scenes
drug use and I've used drugs so I know
what it's about but did you feel like
that had a lot to do with some of the
things falling apart over there in Joe's
world yeah I think when you're using
drugs it's much harder to focus and then
at times throughout Joe's lights he used
enough drugs that he overdosed on a
number of occasions you know and that he
was looking at some pretty hard stuff to
be recreational recreation hard drugs
that's a very difficult thing might be
some recreational alcohol or maybe
people have recreational marijuana in
their life but recreational math man
you're stepping over and meth is a
full-season game you can't yeah meth is
a full season it's not a pickup game you
know meth is uh yeah that's a million
quarters dude that's a lot of overtimes
man
and a lot of people coming to work with
him falling into the same trap how can
they possibly provide the care that you
would hope and the people that are
continuing in that kind of shade of your
side of Wildlife
that part of it is probably the most
detrimental thing that can go on you
need that clear head sharp thinking and
focus to make this work out right Dee
would you ever be up I would be I would
be scared to be on drugs or on a big cat
I would be scared to be on drugs around
a big cat how do you feel about that I'm
scared to be around big cats if I have
allergies going on you know I'm
certainly not going to go out there and
have a few drinks and see what's
happening that just as mad this is this
is a on your toes ready for the serve I
tell people if you don't feel like
you're in a tennis match and that other
guys getting to throw a
hundred-mile-an-hour ball at you right
now but you're not ready for that Tiger
to open that door if you open it you
open the door we say here you go we open
the door right up we say how you doing
there tiger boy come right here come to
me hold we put them together we say
let's follow wha we have very organized
very specific relationships that we
nurture from the time they're very small
were the last ones doing this kind of
action in America it's just faded away
Jojo is doing it different he was
looking for a tiger that didn't like the
bite very often it's come right
everything cody has not been chewed up I
have never been stood up in my life um
we have not been harmed on our facility
we've had bumps and scratches and fall
down but we've certainly had far more
trouble with people tripping and falling
with no cats around at any time a cat
hurting somebody it's just not there
that's not part of what goes on yeah I
know - yeah Joe's over there he likes
cats that like to listen to a CDC and
smoke cigarettes and some of that stuff
blew my mind like they hate I even saw a
cat putting a Copenhagen in his jaw you
know it definitely gets a little a
little more risque over there at his
case
but it seemed like it was just an every
is his whole Tiger complex that GW spot
was just an example of him it was just
it really is it behaves the way the
owner does it seems like like each one
of you guys is camps kind of follows the
owner very erratic behavior you know and
very much behavior of somehow mimimi and
and how it's gonna reflect look and be
about me not about the animals and
certainly not about the big picture that
wildlife desperately needs the big
picture of what her Tigers doing in the
wild and how are you personally trying
to help I talked with you about that a
couple times trying to get him on that
vein one time he got some money and
raised it I think selling prophylactics
he told me and he raised him for rhinos
and he made a donation to international
rhino foundation so that he could help
save rhinos but it was a one-off he
couldn't keep the momentum he needed the
money for other activities in life I
guess
and he just didn't hold it together you
know some unscrupulous buddies to come
along and I think they tore him down
hard as he got more diversified and who
was helping him run the park I think
yeah it's probably the most dangerous
thing he ever did was bring on more
people that were from other more
partners as trouble
he also was Joe when do you where did
you first meet Joe I first met Joe at a
feline conservation Federation meeting
about people that have animals and how
they're gonna care for what they're
doing I was trying to get it that
organization to be able to experience
the wildlife and activities that I have
here maybe 15 years or so ago he visited
because that group was here visiting and
he came through the facility and he got
to see what we're we're doing and what
was happening and he made application to
try and ask the organization to improve
his place give him tips of what could
happen so because of that I sent him
some notes and letters and things about
what he I thought he should do to him
prove the facility and make a better
life from the animals and better life
supports a conservation movement so you
guys developed a relationship right then
it seems like obviously once he got once
he got his own thing going yeah there
was a lot of ego involved in it and then
it also you know he said he had a couple
of boyfriends over there who didn't seem
exactly to be homosexual which is fine
dude who knows what anybody's doing you
know like but do you think that oh yes
look man I grew up right down the street
from the fair they used to come to our
town so I used to hang out with a lot of
Wildcats like that but do you think that
Joe is really there's a lot of drug
induced homosexuality that occurred over
there and sometimes I personally wonder
if Joe was really homosexual do you
think that he was man he seemed that you
know more hardly alien but he had that
edge we're like you know every man that
walks by
it's that exaggerated thing you know
every guy who wants bothered just like
oh yeah look check him out look at that
guy who knows jeans like that leave
those shoulders he was on that vibe you
know just kind of like you were when you
were 14 checking out girls and talking
the inappropriate smack he was yeah that
pretty much as a regular thing I think
Joe had a very difficult childhood and
those guys that rolled out of childhood
in his own traumatised way and that he
found solace in being an outrageous gay
character and he and he did that
finger-snapping outrageous kind of stuff
but on the side man he seemed like
cuddling up with boys was his thing and
I don't mean underage boys I just mean
the younger pretty guys that were around
him he liked those guys you know I saw
you talking a little about Travis Travis
was like uh a big giant teddy bear guy
he did not seem like a gay guy he seemed
like a guy that was just like missing
love and peace and understanding in his
life and and had come from a broken home
things weren't right and Joe filled that
space with all kinds of parts and pieces
and made it made it work out yeah it's a
little bit of the dark arts man it's
like
you know a lot of times I do I you know
I think I blame Joe a little bit like oh
man you really it seemed like he took
advantage of these of this of that young
man but then somebody at some I mean but
then it's all a chain of events somebody
took advantage of Joe or treated him
wrong it's just that kind of stuff just
goes on and on as big choices I mean
there's at the time you say hey I'm
gonna have a relationship with this man
you've crossed the line yeah well and I
don't think he held anybody down Travis
was a man mountain no one was forcing
that guy what to do he crossed the line
and said I guess I'll hold onto that for
you yeah I guess I guess I'll hold onto
that for you with my mouth brother
that's what they're saying a lot of
times here's goes down what um what
about the filmmaking that's one thing
that we don't see that we're not able to
get an insight from as a viewer of you
guys's documentary what about the
filmmaker Eric good about the production
group did it seem like they came in with
one agenda and serviced a different one
or one of your thoughts about them for
that for them right now I have been
advised to not talk about them because
it's gotten to that point where it may
get litigation or something going on so
they said oh don't don't don't give any
what about what ifs about that whole
situation I see that Joe is suing for
ninety four million dollars in the New
York Post day right times I don't
remember which one and I'm four million
that might help get him out of the clink
yeah man what if in that the perfect Joe
amount though 94 million 94 million and
change everything for Joe was 15 years
you know Joe kind of reminds me of like
kind of like a gay Wyatt Earp kind of
like a get like there's there's such a
he first of all he for me he like
reclassifies what a gay man could be
like it's like okay now a gay man has
guns he's like a you know he's got this
kind of like Clint Eastwood kind of
Clint Eastwood vibe what are a few
things that you that you admire about
Joe or things that we see in Joe that we
that we don't get exactly from the
documentary where did you grow up what
state were you in I grew up in Louisiana
Louisiana so maybe and maybe it was
different there I grew up an Arizona on
the Mexico border you know and going
between Mexico and the south and being a
cowboy in California and there were gay
cowboys around you know they were
hardcore gay cowboys look like Cowboys
like Joe totin guys that just had that
edge to them where they just swung in
both ways
I think the joke kind of is emulating
that because he's 55 or so so he's from
a little bit a little era before I think
Joe had good intentions of what he was
doing I think Joe loved the party and I
think Joe was looking for a party where
he could be the king of that party and
there is no doubt that having exotic
animals even just from a little monkey
to a Big O Tiger with you creates a
something flashy that will draw someone
to you and makes a great icebreaker for
that situation now the responsibility
that comes with it is so great that it
will wash it all away but you a lot of
time it takes people a long time to
figure out the flash of the tiger comes
with an a massive amount of
responsibility and time and that the
Tigers not gonna act like a dog unless
you become a world-class trainer which
then requires thousands of hours and
then takes away the party again mmm you
know I think he was just wishing but you
know what I think Joe wished is most and
did the most as Joe wanted to be
Siegfried and Roy yeah that's his mentor
in his mind I would say far more I
thought wanted to be Siegfried and
always I think yeah just just to have
that you know wow factor you know that's
why I did the magic and did other things
and I think that all that was part of
what he was chasing he he looked like a
really hard worker though doc I will say
that and that's just
perception I get was he a hard worker I
think he was I think he was working very
hard at a very difficult thing that
would not he could not keep that shift
going I think there he's got a nice ship
they poked a bunch of holes in it and
who's the one back there with the puck
slinging water out as fast as he can
she was going down yeah he's working his
ass off to sling the water out he's
right next to him and they're drilling
holes growin old Pete is on the other
side and then the animal people that he
met and the other con men shysters and
losers that got their drilling holes and
Joe's back there going happy that bad
he's got a bucket he's going crazy
slinging it over the side doesn't even
realize that it's on until uh they close
that big metal door behind him to Ching
you know should he should Joe exotic be
in prison I would guess it certainly a
portion of the stuff that they say he
did wrong he did some of it I would not
have been shocked if they gave him time
served right that's all right the way
out might even be there cuz he sat there
for a long time being locked up without
being guilty of anything which always
seems strange when that happened so he's
locked up all that time he's suffering
he said he's not the healthiest guy and
he's feeling bad in there and I thought
some people go I'm shocked that he got
22 years I think it's a sign of the
times of just you know people saying
that he's gone really too far that the
things that he did wrong are too big but
I'm really not sure that they were near
as big as other criminals in our system
many of whom are even our politicians we
elected and put in office that I think
crossed a line
far more heinous than anything that
Joe's done and they float by so legal
systems really hard I think if Joe was
had top-notch attorney would have spent
a few million dollars on his defense his
sentence would have been far alive when
when you look when you look back at your
time obviously as a as a cat owner
as a you know an animal ologist i don't
know all the best words a lot of times
but when you look back at your time you
know you know interacting with wildlife
what is something that you want to be
remembered for when your time here in
this realm is done house or remote
remember doctrine and have the our place
that we're trying to hold in Sumatra
declared a national park hey Doc yeah
there you are
okay great we just have one more minute
and we'll be all finished thank you so
much I'm all good I got all the time in
the world I'm sorry to be I don't know
what's happening on your end and my end
it's gone both ways it's probably the
government it could be the government
doesn't want us talking you who knows
it's Carol what the hell it is hey big
cake at 8:00
cats and kittens it's Carol from Big Cat
Rescue I think my god spooky and you
yeah every time I hear it did you ever
meet her husband that is that is a
deceased her previous husband no sir
never met him Darren's favorite in such
a different strange world of buying and
selling pets you know I was zoo guy
there out there in the pet trade and
they just took their pet trade and
flipped it into rescue took all the
animals that they already had rescued
these and made it all part of a big old
scam that ran along and I think they
picked up a few animals in need here and
there but I think a whole lot of it is a
massive misrepresentation there's 12
animals there twelve twelve big cats
it seems like it's interesting yep like
since they run on donation instead of
selling with the service they're able to
provide the donation I guess the the
service for free because they run on
donation and they run as a zoo I mean
you can pay 30 40 bucks an expensive zoo
your 40 bucks and go through their tens
of thousands of people visit the
facility every year and hey the ads
often say the world's greatest
collection of big cats when it's it's
not 10% of what happens here it's not
any hoes we have all of the big cats
here she has just a couple lonely tigers
lonely lion and just a few things yeah
and a donkey somebody said it see one of
them is a donkey in a costume I heard so
a lot of fictional animals there who's
the real Tiger King doc well if there is
a tiger king you know I don't know who
he is you know I mean I am a tiger guy
and I've always been the tiger guy
trying to keep these incredible
creatures at their peak of health to be
a baseline to save them as the future is
coming along because they're just none
left I virtually don't know anybody left
but I could have any relationship with
even barter sell borrow move Tigers back
and forth with that business has faded
in America and even in the zoos it's not
profitable it's not there and tigers are
really on a crash course of not enough
genetics and not enough places to go
even in North America and that
incredible blizzard that there are more
Tigers in America than there are in the
wild is a hundred percent a lie really
II there may be a thousand or so Tigers
in America but are certainly not five
thousand there are hundreds of tigers in
private zoos there are maybe dozens of
people entire country it would have a
tiger somehow and not have federal
oversight USDA zoo license got an
exhibitors license it's unheard of so a
lot of misleading information a lot of
misleading information in the
documentary Oh
endless misleading information about the
stats of big catch and how where they
are and that there's there's somehow a
risk the first responders where the heck
is it there's 10,000 of them hidden out
there you'd hear about it all day long
you know if they weren't really out
there and dude you'd know people still
especially in rural of the rural South
and places that would have a tiger yeah
I passed the law in South Carolina
preventing people from having pet big
cats great apes and bears just because
there was such a hassle everybody always
said man that state is wide open this
vine install it in training Tigers
past the law became complete exemption
to everybody to be able if you had one
you're exempt she got a register if you
had grandfathered in with that animal
you can keep it until it dies you can't
ever get another one would every law
enforcement person all across the state
if we passed that law in January of
eighteen
Emily tigers lions bears showed up zero
nobody showed up because there were none
in the state and there was at least one
somewhere of course there isn't because
no one does that
it wasn't yeah popular in the 80s and
90s but by the new millennium it's faded
it's all over Texas absolutely not true
big census was done about fourteen years
ago I may only found 17 unregistered
Tigers in the state of Texas I believe
that that sound more realistic you know
thousands is a crazy thing they eat a
lot
I see the thousand pounds every day you
need at least 10 to 15 pounds of good
meat every day that's a burden yeah
freezer okay doc enema appreciate it so
much I feel like I learned a lot about
exactly kind of what's going on in the
tiger community I definitely get a
stronger perception of the business of
how you guys are more of like a small
business and how across all facets of
business in America a lot of small
businesses are really being shut down or
being you know cornered in by laws and
this and that
one last question do you have to spend a
lot of money in attorney fees every year
to kind of keep yourself open I would
say I don't spend near as much in
attorneys fees as we do in people
helping us talk to decision makers
policy makers in lobbying trying to get
people to understand lobbying you can
call it that just trying to get out
there make the message happen I go to
Washington numerous times it was right
there in tiger King because I go and I
hold meetings and I go to benefits and I
go places and I speak to people about
incredible importance of Tigers being
alive into the next century into the
next millennium you'd hope and I'm there
you know in Carroll was on there going
yeah he beat us to the office those
people don't want to see her
walk through the door and here's some
whiny baloney about her version of big
cats it's a it's a great big
misrepresentation I'm there too stalling
you the truth this is an incredibly
precious character it needs to exist
you're right to touch him is incredible
here you go
I brought Tigers to Congress Adam
walking the halls of Congress meeting
everybody and the congressmen were so
excited they had 700 people in line one
day a SP Bono Cain Bono didn't get a
fraction of the blast the tiger cubs got
because everybody is in love with them
by just contact by idea a tiger is of
blessing it's an incredible character
and if somebody wants to change anything
about it change something about how the
regulations are about care and what
happens to them that you could enforce
different rules but because of that is
exactly how the other wild character
that you see in tiger King Tim start oh
yeah with them about care they say his
care wasn't proper because they say his
care wasn't proper he doesn't get to
have Tigers anymore that's not uncommon
it's far more common that they take
people's right to have a tiger then that
they somehow say oh yeah those guys just
can keep them it's just not done but
those crazies are trying to say that
they're everywhere right they're hiding
out they always do that about everything
it's about everything they're everywhere
yeah maybe everywhere they're all yeah
everything's every it's everywhere it's
in your house exactly yeah there's sex
trafficking in your backyard I'm like no
they're not I don't have a yard
as always it's everywhere you love
people love to be fanatic right they
really do man popular notion and that
extremism was focused on us a bit
throughout the show if there's somehow
someway something inappropriate going on
which is by the attack of the silliest
dang front somehow it's got something to
do with a cult like there's no ritual
here or not
we're not out there doing anything
there's no one applying to work in some
way it's inappropriate or unique the
only thing that I'm culty about is I
believe I stretch and do yoga and I get
hurt less and when I have a giant Tiger
jump on me if I have that morning it
hurts a lot less than if I haven't
stretched that morning yeah the edge of
the cult there is Yoga for impact of
tigers climbing on you you know that's
it and Cody does the same thing you want
to be warmed up and ready going out and
having a great more time with the tiger
is still a boxing match it is very
extreme so well is that crazy stuff well
we love look I appreciate the time and I
hope to as soon as I American back up
and running and I'm over in South
Carolina I want to come through and take
a tour of the facility and and get to
meet you guys in person
I appreciate the behind the scenes it
gives me a better interpretation kind of
of what's going on over there and just
kind of a little bit more knowledge or
you know your point of view of what's
happening in the Tiger world and um just
want to thank you and thank Cody as well
all good stuff yep and Bali and sugreev
with the chimp brothers to come out and
say hi oh yeah definitely man I think
you got a couple of chimps waiting on
dinner so I don't want to keep you guys
all night but I'll certainly encourage
our viewers and listeners to get over
there and check out your facility when
it's back open and um and thank you guys
for taking care of those animals over
there and thank you very much coming
here is like no place on earth love to
see it come on all right we'll do it doc
Cody be good for a gang man thank you
cheers man thank you
[Music]
like these leaves I must be but when I
reach that round I'll share this peace
of mind I can feel it but it's gonna
take
a little town for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]